who this week's Android live from
droidcon Holland this week we're a very
nice just-in-time delivery we what also
waiting for some sign this week will be
slightly more sane than last week and
this guy say hi to the internet don't be
this we could be a little more sane last
week crazy robots we couldn't really
hear anything anyone said but we've got
a whole lot of questions in the in the
moderator today you can find that
developers.google.com/live and we'll
rock on hey Sparky could see you again
hey yo see could see him you back
from from Munich and Paul is that poor
handsome could see hopefully you've got
some questions for us today it's so much
last week will yes decays and api's and
phones and everything this week yeah
next all shipping some people very
exciting but who knows where you can get
Nexus 4 how can I get a cruiser like
calm CIC easy part
and we have a big first of a big Android
BBQ yeah barbecue this world also making
mervich you had a barbecue yeah well
let's get some content into the show and
there's anyone inside the Hangout for
the question for us this week going once
going twice
anything on NFC I've got one just just
through these lock screen widgets do you
have full access to like NFC and other
resources on the lockscreen widget no ok
core didn't think so okay it's yeah
pretty much just the same as a desktop
widget in most respects you just set the
flag to say whether you want desktop or
not screen on both inside your manifest
in the declaration Winnie the Pooh's
just joined us in the Declaration of the
lots of religion but I think so far the
the abundance of not screen widgets have
been clot which use a single font weight
right in fact I think this is the NFC
chip powered down until screen on and
unlocked
that sounds good thank you so what I
expect thanks guys
yes is joined twice I believe
okay oh my Wi-Fi so this one will drop
some do you have the dude we have a
bumper crop of moderator questions this
week I count I believe 17 moderator
questions you can tell you looked at the
number which tells you how many but I
actually you know leave leave it to me
to use an order in operation where a
constant time will suffice
let's get straight into a okay best
practices for unit testing Android apps
what is Google using and what's in the
pipeline jimmy and jey and a robot iam
UI on theater of your other to come hang
out I just walked out at a talk on
testing and folks with a so-so Sparky
you wanted to give it to the yeah I I
gave a link to the to the developer Docs
and and my only answer so the well the
answer the question is what is Google
using internally and then that tends to
vary my app so you know most people
using the I've been hearing a lot about
mojito gaining popularity since mojito
added support from looking out and
asking really really popular there's
also the new UI Automator
frameworks which are internal testing
team and developed in the net just being
open source and the latest in the latest
tools release one of my favorites it's a
service called testdroid calm who offer
an awesome and recorder service any
other favorites it's just a unit I think
is perfect really I think best bet maybe
start there this is a really local
testing the tester it's awesome you
getting across all devices and one so
there's other things like device
anywhere
the people that you send more sort
things that you can test on devices get
screenshots so I think testdroid adds an
extra load of stuff with it yes
oh yeah whichever one you choose them if
you do them all it all comes down to the
quality of the test scripts in the end
are your test cases valid can you
actually get them to pass and fails and
this isn't 10 photo and yeah you also
split be called out and from powder 366
I'm going to ask specifically about
juice I would say very heavily I think
at one time the Google Drive app might
be used if I'd written it that still
holds mostly because of the runtime
henze resolution stuff or the reflection
a guy's pretty expensive on lopat
devices so I don't think we use juice
hugely and there's this new crop of
other and pencil injection frameworks
which using like ahead of time like I
said compile time and resolution so
stuff like that's the bus interesting
things and yes you know there compile
time you can see the code it spits out
you can debug it and there's no
additional cost on run time which is we
could really really care about so
they're not so much juice and live at
all which is an upcoming it's not
launched yet but then we heard about it
a couple weeks ago is the Square guys
the perfect open sources of awesome code
and they're working on a framework
called spoon which we had a preview of
and Jake Wharton from square okay very
good talk at DevOps a couple weeks back
and he gave us a sneak preview of the
spoon framework we should be going open
source soon which lets you run your test
across a bunch of devices and pull all
the results off them and see screenshots
and make sure you're not breaking like a
layout on device why lots of cool tools
out there and now that question
okay that is next muffin I've got I've
got one question based on the dependency
injection is anyone ever used spring
because I heard some time ago Springs
Bing Bing in Java but they were doing
some stuff with Android anyone had any
use for that I have not used spring in
my former life as a je my gut reaction
is it's a kind of a whole massive stack
which scares me about you know all these
things happening a runtime and Android
that want to make sure that you know you
know for some developer convenience
you're not sacrificing any performance
rent on that so I haven't looked at def
I have some concerns
yeah I've kind of always had at me a
sort of vision I can never really paid
much attention to it
I've not needed to I guess okay thanks
us yeah have you got the you know make
sure it's not doing anything at runtime
especially so next next question from
the rear I want to perform an action
when a user is near a location I have a
proximity alert and a service that runs
indefinitely is this good practice in
terms of battery use performance etc
other you know can we provide other
ideas does maps check in or might alert
attempt a etc I think one thing has not
been a real strength of art of our
engine API in the past their rito
published a blog post not quite a year
and a half ago called deep dive into
location that's worth checking out he
calls out things like passively
listening for location updates that
other apps requests that you don't have
to wake up the the radio is yourself to
do it don't use you know don't use any
finer location than you need if you're
you know if if you're still several
metres away from your destination you
don't actually need to know within 20
meters where you are and then my advice
is also just use some some estimation to
reduce the frequency of your updates if
you know that it's going to be 15
minutes before you get to your
destination you don't need to check your
location every five minutes yeah yeah
reto is a Google i/o 2011 talk as well
pro tips and more you might already
watch pro tips - did someone open source
the two implementations yeah so I think
the guys from Nevada
they put a vacation
library where they basically took Rito's
tons and tons of awesome best practice
code and wrapped up into a library
project so you can actually just listen
to a certain broadcasts and there's a no
one I think as well from the guys from
quite so Stephano and quite I think use
aspectj
to do the similar kind of thing so at
compile time so two implementations that
so yeah I don't mean reaches post
specifically just the case of geofencing
and I wouldn't say having a service room
the whole time is really the best thing
you basically want your service advising
as possible it's not redoing any work so
you probably use a combination of the
combination of the passive location
provider and inexact repeating alarms to
you know grab locations whenever anyone
else fires application provider and also
notify your app with a passive provider
but then you know if you need to no need
to check the minimum interval every 15
20 minutes whatever use the in executive
repeating alarms as well you know I mean
I'm totally confused as to why they need
to have a service running all the time
as well that's kind of the whole point
for activity alerts you're kind of
waiting for something to kick off then
you do something rather than have it
invent one yeah so I think in in
practice right from the start there's
something that maybe we're not
understanding or actually need to just
read think about it in different way is
the idea of having service running on
time just scares me and love them
Yeah right maybe running a service all
the time if you're doing something like
opportunistic you know a location
matching say where am I now and what
points of interests are near me you know
sort of like the field trip app or
something like that maybe then it makes
a little bit more sense yeah yeah but
you know then we put in location the
whole time right you want the service to
stop itself as soon as you stop doing
any work and you know the schedule
itself to be woken up again after after
a period and then stop it up right yeah
I mean I guess you also get to a point
where you want to use like the cell
tower location is just a rough guide
wait for that to change sort of try and
listen listen off the pass of things and
if you need more fine-grained GPS then
start thinking about how you can sort of
try and avoid it and when you do use it
use it sparingly yeah yeah
Tippy's ask this one question in the
chat how can we access a ListView item
filled using a simple cursor adapter
that contains a progress bar not bind to
the cursor date should have read I read
that build using a simple cursor adapter
can I explain yes yes please okay
in the ListView I have the items ended
with the simple cursor adapter okay but
I have one view more is a Fergus bar and
from a different treat I needed to
access to this progress bar and update
the value I don't want to update the
database because you can image if I want
to update the database each in
millisecond I will ever the the access
to the SD card millions of time so I
want to access just to the Ville over
the list view and
get the item find that the progress bar
and update all of this from a different
rate so you've got a list and one of the
items in that list will have a progress
bar going across it each each I don't
have one progress bar
you've got async tasks running running
downloading some dan-levitan and I need
to refer to the progress bar and update
the value because the items is painted
to the simple cursor adapter is pinned
at the with an L with the cursor I
cannot simple just get the position or
something like that and access to the
view you don't know which particular
item you want to allow that right
hi I lost - I lost a we are around one
week to find a solution but nothing to
do because from maybe no but if you if
you extend ListView and then use forgot
the term for it maybe something more
like a custom view attack adapter where
you you you have your own code that
draws the view and at that time you can
spin arrow as my chest
I am adjusted to using the regular
simple cursor adapter for this ListView
I can't use a custom little adapter you
can extend a simple cursor adapter and
then use the to override get hue method
so it will fit your needs and then if
you use the view container that has you
know the tag for each item in the cursor
you can do you get tagged Josi canal
sorry sorry to stop you go see I really
do if we are the inside that the
get view or new view etc but not from
outside the treat not from asynctask
okay that's in task I have nothing to do
with the get view no you can you can add
a new method to the simple cursor
adapter that you extend and then from
that adapter you can get the position
and check the tag and if the tag is the
same time you need from the cursor then
you can update the view you understand
what I mean yeah of course the turn is
done yeah it's interesting as proposed
yeah yeah I think this is probably what
try to do that I instinctively code to
solve that problem
I just I I guess the way you're saying
you don't know which item in the list
you want to update you need to find that
way of matching the two of which you do
in the adapter one way or the other but
yeah if you extend the simple cursor
adapter then you can start doing a lot
of this stuff and it's one of those
things where you have to code yourself
busy trying to be something outside of
what the pre-built cursor or the
pre-built adapters design today yeah
make sure you use the view holder design
oh yeah if you hold her and also use a
hash map or something for the faster
using and then when you use the view
holder set the hash map tag to the same
view so you can find it faster yeah I am
I believe that this is the right
solution I was just looking something to
don't change
all the structure don't change the
simple cursor adapter with something
else just looking for that is why the
custom adapter is there - can I have one
more question probably yeah
anyway for known system application to
write in the secure settings no no way
but it's changed something in the 4.2 we
had a setting secure what is the what is
this so some studies allude to blunder
settings from system settings they
didn't we just cure them so some you
can't read
right system settings or at least into
the tables and some of those items have
now been moved into global settings
where they're now read-only the main one
of those is flight mode
something's just like in multi-user kind
of tablets it just doesn't make sense to
have a per user setting for like flight
mode it should be like a global setting
so though some refactoring of where the
settings live support multi-user yes if
you want if you've got a widget which
used to turn flight mode on and off now
it's best to send the user to the
settings screen for flight mode to the
network and wireless setting Springs
that's the only place now if I
understood well there are many many
applications that use a batteries level
etc chatter that must be updated for the
four point two right it doesn't fail all
it does is just return to say that they
didn't write the value it's the same
situation I see application it's not
gonna throw an exception
is there any other way we can say first
save the information to some word in the
system like is that like the sector that
K is accessible for only from an
application that were right to the
information I'm looking for some
somewhere were to write some information
and only my application can access to
this information
you're not like well in your instances
you can just any file you can open it as
private and then it's not accessible to
anyone elses your own awareness sorry
when it's maybe multiple of your own
applications or just one application one
application you know although all the
files all the data for your application
is protected yeah yeah yeah protected
the windy route to the mobile and uses
some Explorer they can find any files
any database and think oh nothing is
protected and it's routed I mean if you
want to keeps things so that they can't
read it after the device has been routed
I don't know in light your own
encryption scheme or something is coming
but you'd have to write
yeah like you might be autistic Isoroku
I'm not certain so for the most part to
use case yes for the most part yeah you
just use the protection that Android
offers you but if you're concerned about
reducers as well
yeah I know that I know that the data
over the application is accessible only
from the application but if they use
some to not work around that they can
find at the data they can change
everything I'm looking and now if if til
last years that 20% of the people have a
rooted phone now they are 80% anywhere
near the highway yeah I definitely say
less than 1% of people have a rigid
frame watch at the end of the day is is
kind of argument mute like yeah it's not
secure computing environment right like
this is a piece of code running on the
user's device and untrusted device right
you can't be a hundred percent sure you
in this ways you can help and you know
Android is a Mexican but any day it's
code running on their device if it's
super secure then don't keep on the
device keep on the server yeah at any
point anyone could run this on an
emulated or simulated environment and
get access to that data anyway so
there's not going to be a place that
you're gonna be able to put that to keep
it totally secure because because in my
in one of our application until version
4.2 of Android we argue we was using the
encryption a is a yes encryption but I
don't know why starting a the version
4.2 this is this is a it's crashing when
we try to a quest secure
you know what yeah there was a change
here secure elements some people were
making bad assumptions at how about how
secure random secure random worked I
think we have a blog post coming out and
that's right yeah probably more
information on it soon but uh my dad
details at hand but yeah the
implementation of secure random
has changed slightly and so if you were
making bad assumptions about how it
worked then okay thank you
we have seen if you have to break an
iron
pingas offline and i'll trying to get
accept changing you to make but we have
a real question sir and what did you
suggest doing this time did we find that
the final solution how could we can work
around the problem over encryption in
4.2 so if you have stopped working you
get completely fails on 4.2 then I guess
the temporary measure you could set a
max SDK on your apk so that 4.2 users
can't download it would be one way to do
it until you fix the bug okay we'll try
and but yeah we can resolve this issue
think tickets after the show and I'll
send you okay I will do this thank you
I'm yet as nexus there will be a blog
post going out soon the wider audience
okay
somebody has joined us in the - the
common road for not wearing a hat it's
why we're facing this way in the
corridors that way it's just silent
brightness and you can't see at all
mm-hmm who said that I can't see you
okay on to the emoji funny question
someone wants that one okay crazy I
guess in the UK asks what happens to the
work effects in a pool during some
network queries to be displayed on the
UI when the activity is destroyed
eg config change and what our activities
and tasks described in terms of Android
OS and Linux processes and users so good
question and so generally an Android
application is I use like there's like
one user application at install time you
can have that's not quite true you can
actually share the user ID between
applications if you set a flag in your
manifest but generally it's one user to
an application and a single process
which is round at the end so when you
when your application starts and yeah
the process is started it's folks from
me from zygotes
and you get one fret so that javathread
which maps exactly to the linux see
friend
so then yeah but then you have a many
many different ways which you can be
multitasking after that so when you ask
what happens to work of threads in the
pool during some network queries and
that's kind of an open-ended question it
depends how you create those words
meaning if you're talking about async
tasks which I suspect you might be then
those threads will continue to
completion but then they won't really
have a context anywhere but if you you
know go do your own things like you're
going to create a thread itself or if
you're going to use an executor service
or an intent service and loaders or any
of these good things then then you can
have these tasks that persist the
destruction of your activity and mean
creation of the object and so it's kind
of an open-ended question yeah async
tasks it's convenient but not always the
right answer to your to your problem
take a look at some other stuff like mmm
intent services and handler friends and
other such mechanisms as well and don't
need your activities so I hope your
question right my course that's where my
sort of icing on that cake is is if you
are going to run an async task either
make sure that you don't rely on
information from your context or if you
do then when your context ie your
activity goes away kill the task kill
the async task before you do yeah yeah I
see ease xington quite frequently I
think because it's so convenient right
so easy to create and get these
callbacks which there's all the
marshaling of the affairs all nicely for
you but you end up you know if you have
to survive like rotation changes and
things like that you end up having to
write some extra stuff so I've actually
been more inclined to use and handle for
these days and pass messages and you get
much more control over you know yeah I
still like the occasional in nine thread
just checking in a runnable kennix do it
in mind and coming back
it's not something that's just need to
be taken off the main thread crow tip if
you're gonna do that make sure you're
setting the process so if you do create
you know just a Fred
make sure you setting the Android OS
stop process not the Javadoc mangaka
process this is a bit confusing she's
two processes one indeed authority
background yeah
and that actually goes into a background
thread in the kernel as well okay happy
you got to answer the question to answer
good question right not wrong Cespedes
just about to ask if he had a question
but he's display is there anything
coming through on the G+ thread just
what's the lot I think crews are like
plushy you try them here selling them
you can get here I think Oh follow
Arrancar porn
she's too low maintenance
yeah okay okay so a frequent commentator
Yan Souza and asks how can do a
horizontal scroll on ListView and like
the GPS application in landscape
customer but you could talk to Chris
Bane's he is currently working on a
project to do one there are numerous
other projects but you're right
currently there isn't a system widget
which we recommend using to do
horizontal scrolling one on this tree
there was some work on something in the
support area
removed it's already 8 so I don't know
what the sakes of that is but it might
you might yeah the reason they I mean
gallery got deprecated because it wasn't
being supported and it didn't do things
quite right they're a bunch of
implementations if horizontal issue I
predict will have 10 good
implementations soon instead of none
yeah so just search the community the
main one is this stick for one that's
definitely using an adaptive patent
because all my other if you do that then
hopefully whenever the next one comes up
whatever it might be it's gonna be
adaptive base I hope it would be two
months you have to change Jessie because
I yeah country alright one take a look
at ListView and how it does recycling as
well because that's pretty cute I
believe apps this view is its own asking
the community will ride maybe Sparky
yeah
the next question is there any way to
enable multi-user support on a VD with
Android 4.2 in the latest ATT 21 the
option in settings is missing and I
can't see any option when creating the
new AVD unfortunately I don't know so if
you create they used to be the case it's
made to the high resolution device
you've got the tablet layout creating a
high resolution device means you get
there no I there may be some AM flag
hope mm-hmm so before we launch
multi-user people who had already found
it in JV in 4.1 and there was an
activity manager settings you could
toggle from online to turn on just me so
try making a bigger emulator seriously
and
and you have a look back through the
people who emerge to your label until
point one is 2.0 don't specify where
they've tried it
creating a tablet yeah so when you
create a 4.0 emulator did you create a
large screen or large alert device
it's yeah I think that's a really good
suggestion you can devices yes you to
when t1 t1 is a new device the second to
have you can just choose the device that
you want and choose next to ten or Nexus
7 on that it would be interesting to see
if it had multi I love multi-user
unfortunately I've gotten lazy I have
actually not yet created a 4.2 at abd
I've been using only devices right Nico
advanced is using one of my favorite
features so that it's in the activity
options class where you actually create
these nice scaled animations when you
launch your new activity so you can if
you have a recent for example where it
scales up from a thumbnail to the full
screen which I think it's a really
really cool way of retraining context
for these are and and it says yeah they
love it but how do they do the reverse
so you can do this you can cut you can
set a custom animation so you won't be
able to like scale it to view or to a
bitmap like you can with the activity
options but you can just set a custom
animation to scale it to certain place
so it's the standard activity but set
pending transition so ripen override
hinging in the transition like this I
think so I think you can do that - yeah
you can't do a scale down to a thumbnail
don't like that but you can get close
bitches haha googling like Logan's David
Lee overflow answers come up before our
official documentation as long as they
point to our documentation is fine
Chapman Romans talk at this year's
DevOps cover at this exact point I don't
think there's torture going live until
December and yeah they're taught this
and it was a three-hour talk they gave
me those are approximately four hundred
awesome tips so we didn't manage to
remember them all but I'll be watching
that just yeah
document all of those tips he also has
added hangout toolbox
what the hell's will happen now I think
you'll see should just be joining the
Google bus hangout and then it is
consistent this pull out a new Josi
plug-in of the week last week it's me
more wasn't it
well the G personally it's a very very
plugging them the Weaver no okay
participants unknown user I think that
might know I know use it use its on
there you'll see okay well that's
something that you'd like to answer does
anyone understand this question from
order I'm going as a boarder asks how
can you make a dialog appear as swiping
in a fragment I want to show a dialogue
over a fragment to mark a multivalued
question
a fragment is in a viewpager how can
this be achieved but this is like you
move the fragment across dialogue comes
up well we can do that yeah listen for
the viewpager transitions page change I
think he doesn't want the fragment what
are you doing Nick doing that then
throwing up a dialogue it's a very user
perspective just sounds nasty if you
really needed to do something which
blocks mental that something had been
fielded I would
we have an extra view in your layout
which was shown inside the viewpager and
then have that enabled and then once
they finish interacting with it get rid
of it but not you have a dot on top just
have it as a view inside your lay online
good idea so as you swipe across it's
already there and then they can dismiss
it I'm not sure I completely get it
maybe he means he just wants to you know
like you touch it and it pops up these
are what you could populate the field
with and then I close this down again
yeah that's what I thought that the
fragment doesn't really move the in the
pager basically when it touches then you
get a download with all the possible
options to choose from Terra sauce to me
like even you're a traditional dialog
activity the transparent background
would be just fine that's so not masa
five dialogues yeah it sounds like what
you don't do is like a multi-step
wizardy type behavior in which case you
might want to take a look at some
awesome code which Roman Nurik extremely
open source so if you go to
code.google.com slash p / Roman Nurik
- myths - code Roman Nurik - and my head
there is a sample or you can look at his
own GPS speed from a month or so that we
search for Roman just follow Romeo
critical and he's a wizard yeah this is
a seven visit
I'm sure you could do a hangout okay
next whoa
Jake you may come well yeah unless
there's anything coming in on double
tears anyone checking the YouTube
comments because they're always
hilarious and some valuable no questions
in G+ okay good
moderator moderator up okay I have a
fragment from the spot library
containing a view with a flip animation
on the way artist it's kind of flipping
a book page page sticks to the finger
however at 85 degrees view disappears
clipped question mark how can I change
this or should I use OpenGL Wow I'm just
wondering if like is this just a simple
matter of geometry that when you look at
a like when you look at a text for
edge-on there's nothing to see I mean
yeah I wanted that's that's why I asked
him you know is this like is it just
doing it me or is it a transient
condition that comes back as you scroll
past you know 95 degrees or something we
have 3d rotations yeah I'm also
wondering is this an issue with our
OpenGL check is actually just
manifesting hyperaccelerated equals
false and try just just to rule out the
possibility that there's some
complication due to hardware UI and
worth taking and then if we want to get
fancy about it if you if you think it
might be just a visual artifact because
you're viewing the page edge on then
animate have been to page actually then
you've got a question for us the rather
know that you meet it yes
finish up on that on that one as well I
think it sounds I was just gonna say
dodge the issue by actually giving the
giving the page some depth you know warp
it bend it or something so that actually
occupies all three dimensions I'm trying
to work out who you is it just
transition animation or is it following
your finger in which case are you using
viewpager perhaps because it's so then
the latest and reads the support library
introduced the new class page
transformer which lets you buy an effect
as as you paging so that might actually
be able to create this same kind of
thing I'm not sure if that's what you're
doing but take a patient something
where's your second it's the first time
I've ever seen Cedric without his hat on
and we were wearing heads irony Cedric
from should we what's your question just
unmute first or it's going to be very
hard to be here we go hi Sparky Hallie
hey Robby was a yeah good I like you to
be man right I'm just have some quick
question about Android development for a
kind of application management but using
kind of session management and stuff so
is there any effective way to do kind of
special management in Android just like
we do in in Microsoft technologies using
this special session management services
and stuff so is there any kind of
inbuilt thing which we can manage or do
we need to dispatch some tokens using
kind of shared preferences or internal
storage
are you talking about no I mean if we
have a noggin I mean we don't have an
external server which manages decisions
but the server only organizes the
username and password only thing we need
is to make sure the user is in the right
kitchen or just to make sure if user do
not make any activity within past two of
us so existing session goes out to login
again I mean currently what we are doing
is we are storing everything in SQLite
server in SQLite databases and whenever
there is no touch activity for
predefined period of time and we are
forcing the user to make the login
activity once again but I thought if
there is any kind of standard way to
manage everything
okay I don't my monitors showing these
questions in the same orders yours I
think we skipped a couple already but
maybe they're further down the line and
yours did you get Cedric from
Switzerland which of the following
Bluetooth Low Energy Arkin actions can
we perform an API 17 none my answer was
none yeah
Midwest supports the low energy profile
Nexus 4 but I don't think you can
actually interact with the API from your
application sorry
Oh No
Gabriel Hitler from Berlin wants to know
is it allowed to send a user to a
website to pay for the app using well
their wallet or PayPal or some other
payment method after maybe using the app
for a period of time for free no and I
said no no a Google one is the only
allowed payment processor for apps in
Google Play with the exception of this
sort of media exam
for content which is participa land
consumable in many different places yeah
and I know that the next thing you're
going to say is but payment services
inside in-app billing or paid
applications don't support the country
that I want if you want to play services
there's no can I also add Google in-app
payment and also have a PayPal payment
there's an option or you had an
available option he's on let's just be
let's just be Google services listed in
the Play Store or a single one yeah yeah
yeah just a single one of course the
beauty of the Android Marketplace or the
the Android ecosystem is there is more
than one app store we don't lock you
into just one channel for buying apps
and if people prefer to have other
payment options besides just Google
Wallet then there are lots of other
stores they can list in yeah
distribution policy supports this it
says you must use the approve and an
approved payment authorizer magic it was
hoping that someone from the dutch
android usergroup would walk past so we
could grab them and they could plant
that awesome user group they found it
exactly one year ago happy birthday one
conference in that area yeah happy
birthday to the dutch android usergroup
if your hand comes back round I will
certainly grab him they're gonna be
watching the show right now from
wherever you're watching this show from
by now the rest of the Internet's we
have just been draining the Hangout by a
new member welcome Paul is there
anything you'd like to talk about
Android related
I thank you I just had one question in
terms of Android is kind of why why the
war on SD cards why the war on SD cards
only Nexus devices right
we just want a good user experience on
SD cards have too many failed just user
interactions user experiences everything
about them
there's no good model for having an SD
card inside a device if you can start
installing apps to it you pop it out and
then no longer exists if you start
installing apps to it you mount it on
another computer
they are generally formatted and can't
be accessed from both devices at the
same time you know there's just so many
reasons it's not end up having to get
the user to manage store interests and
then at some point you want to upgrade
from a 16 GB or 32 gig and you have to
somehow get your techie friend to
manually copy over everything from one's
the other including all the hidden files
so things don't break and when you buy a
new phone my stuff is on the internal
storage of a phone and I get a new phone
because it's cold or whatever how can I
get the next Nexus or whatever ever it
is I have to do exactly that process
that you just described there to copy
all the stuff my data from my distant
phone no you do not because you can do a
back up through the Gmail account you
can do it also you can use the auto
download - all the apps
I mean even if a million other cases
that an SD card isn't a good user
experience for the majority of users
they are sought after by techies and
people who like to carry a lot of
content around but it's not a great user
experience and you had the choice right
yeah I had a rumor versions of Android
are not going to allow readwrite access
to two SD cards wait what you know about
future versions of Android from someone
of a friend of a friend you know the
kind of thing
like a future version of Android it's
gonna disable readwrite I think that if
that did happen it would be like a
manufacturer wouldn't be able to work
around it
I mean Asus have managed to do quite a
good job I think of including multiple
SD card support on their devices you
have a micro SD USB slots all these
different things and it works very well
I mean it is an open platform that wait
are you actually talking about the new
you permission for reading the SD card
is that possibly yes okay so we've
introduced a new permission as of an API
16 to wear as optional permission to
recur at the moment well prior to 16 you
know the SD card with world readable and
anyone can read anything on that and the
security issues that into because of
this and mistreating it so yeah we
anticipation but so if we didn't break
all the apps and give people some time
to afraid it is optional at the moment
so if you have the divert if you have
the developer options you can go in and
turn it on and enforces permission to
only applications with the read SD card
permission like these like right SD card
permission we can actually read from it
but yes in some future release we've
said that we're going to make the
default to import us so yesterday since
we're giving me app developer some time
to update their apps to ask for this new
permission but we're not taking anything
away of this case Oh sentries back and
he's been a bought a hat Cedric's back
with hat again I have needs
it's wonderful to give a quick plug for
Android VM
yes ok hello everyone
so I'm Cedric from China Mobile and I'm
at white cone and you're doing
conference tomorrow on the software news
calling on the OEM it's on with virtual
machine on your PC so you can do you can
emulate your your on the way it
smartphone and tablet and make all your
tests you want and immolate all the
sensor of a mobile and it's quite a
quite famous open-source project we have
more than 200,000 downloads and so we
can go and help us to develop it and to
test it for us
we have three hunting members but I
don't think they're all it's a good
amount and everywhere so so himself
of course they apps to them and but
there are a lot of one one-man show in
which around the Netherlands over in
East and South also and we tend to
observe them all but I think if you say
we're going to have something about NFC
we have it in there ain't open it's a
bit so it's good good thing yeah I'm
letting people back whenever you can go
to www.youtube.com the person and reduce
yeah so we're gonna talk as well pa pa
you 2002 have also a good onion Paris
for next year London android usergroup
Paris and Purdue group and
yeah okay
about the GCM one quick question
basically the Android model is that apps
are to be put on the background you
press the home button and the app
continues to work until the system close
it down and the process is successfully
terminated by the system if the user
presses for stop then the GCM messaging
won't work on the device that's what I
saw is it is that the designed framework
for the GCM to work on the not at all
yours actually running it so anyway from
verge of the system it should just be
going straight through to your broadcast
receiver right and again picked up and
starting whichever parts your
application and needed to process the
message yeah but I'm not getting
anything
basically when I impress the for stop
under settings which will unregistering
from the service
yeah I'm sure because the unregistering
from services only when the application
we have an exit button on our app that
keeps the device register to the GCM
well that's a bad thing anyway you have
an exit button on your app that keeps
that then closes the GCM connection did
you say no it doesn't close the GCM it
keeps the device registered and closes
all the other stuff so the user
basically doesn't see us on foreground
or background we kill the service for
the communication and everything
terminated and basically then you can
get a GCM message but when I do the for
stop on our app it basically stops
sending delivering the GCM it is a
slightly strange education people
shouldn't be hitting for stop on apps
yeah I know but basically you have users
the dual-tone they're gonna do it if
they don't trust your application so it
seems more like an app issue that if
you've got users hitting full stop on
your application they're doing it for
the exact reason that they want to stop
it popping up all these messages and
it's their only way probably know
basically I'm more paranoid than most
people so basically when I use the phone
every time I don't have any things on
the recent and I go to the settings and
just press or stop on all the
applications kills broadcast as well
best reception it'll be kind of a mac
off period it's kind of full stuff and
then topics preventing it from being
restarted so quick so like I mean yeah I
mean if I generally don't full stop
applications yeah me too but just for
testing I I did it so and that's that's
when I found that that issue users
complained that during the four stop
time it's in a different status isn't
there yeah it's in the application
stopped State exactly I was wondering
where and there's things you can do to
get around it but I don't really suggest
yeah yeah I think rich is nailing it on
it on the head really it sounds like
there is some behavior force stuff that
we don't understand and you should try
and understand why your users are for
stopping your app might be they honestly
if I was pressing the exit button
messages to come in you know I guess I
would yeah I guess sigh now if you
changed the word exit to sign out and we
make a lot more sense
now users would understand what's doing
you know we have this sign-on button but
we also have the exit button to keep us
working on the is that little Mir
yeah just woke up yeah actually we
should shouldn't have worked in Europe
because it is time for us to quit today
and we're not allowed to run over to
take this as a big Android BBQ for
joining us is down and we should be back
in the normal environment next week till
next week normal time next week as well
Wednesday 2:00 p.m.
keep Android make awesome apps so next
week and the first question we've mine
that you left